du karaté du taekwondo du kendo à la
place de l'entretien d'embauché
traditionnels voilà la session de
recrutement organisée par thales une
vingtaine de candidats à participer à
cet événement innovant un premier
contact établi avec les recruteurs à
travers une initiation à ces disciplines
ça change énormément du recrutement
habituel en fait ça permet vraiment
d'être décontracté et de voir une autre
vision en fait du recrutement classique
au début un peu stressé intimider ce
qu'on connaît personne et puis ça tient
peut être là on communique facilement et
on se met à aller très vite candidats et
recruteurs se retrouvent au même niveau
dans une position d'apprentissage des
arts martiaux le moyen de déceler des
potentiels pour le site thalès
d'elancourt je pense que ma relation en
tant que manager avec mes collaborateurs
et la confiance que je leur donne et que
leur attribue je trouve qu'on retrouve
cette cette image là dans les arts
martiaux je trouve que déjà le
comportement la posture le dialogue qui
s'instaure la fluidité qui peut
s'installer entre nous rien par un petit
échange on décèle scinder cette
ouverture osé essayer je trouve que sa
place à transparaît tout de suite dans
les changes
j'ai déjà envie de retrouver des jeunes
filles avec qui j'ai discuté là et voilà
d'en savoir plus sur elle respect
détermination agilité et écoute les
valeurs défendues par thales des
comportements essentiels dans la
pratique des arts martiaux l'attitude
qu'on peut corporelle il ya que les
personnes qui vont y aller tout de suite
s'impliquer dans la démarche
c'est ce qui s'appliquait aux arts
martiaux peu s'impliquent s'appliquer
dans le monde professionnel
après l'initiation les candidats ont pu
échanger avec les recruteurs des
discussions autour des postes proposés
par le groupe industriel spécialisé dans
le secteur de la défense